Jeff sessions is the American attorney
general sort of the chief law
enforcement officer the chief lawyer of
the United States government he seems
confused about how the United States
legal system works or maybe he just
doesn't really like the state of Hawaii
session said last week that he is quote
amazed that a judge quote on an island
in the Pacific was able to block Donald
Trump's majority Muslim country
immigration ban check it out we are
confident that the president will
prevail on a peel and particularly in
the Supreme Court is not the Ninth
Circuit so this is a huge matter
I really am amazed at a judge sitting on
an island in the Pacific can issue an
order that stopped seeing the president
United States from what appears to be
clearly his statutory and constitutional
powers so if you haven't heard this
story you're probably thinking Oh on
some island on the Pacific what there
must be some foreign country in the
Pacific that's interfering with our
legal system is it is Fiji is Fiji
interfering is it the Federated States
of Micronesia no the judge that Jeff
sessions was referring to is US District
Judge Derek Watson an American federal
judge and the obscure and outlandish
island in the Pacific the Jeff Sessions
was referring to is called Hawaii which
according to my research is a state in
the United States of America last month
judge Watson was the judge who struck
down trumps second attempt at a majority
Muslim country immigration banned and
now Jeff sessions is taking it out on
Hawaii u.s. senator from Hawaii amazing
hero no tweeted quote hey Jeff Sessions
the island in the Pacific has been the
50th state for going on fifty-eight
years and we won't succumb to your dog
whistle politics Hawaii senator Brian
Schatz tweeted mr. attorney general you
voted for that judge and that island is
called 'allahu it's my home have some
respect when someone like Donald Trump
says something ignorant about the courts
it's bad it's really really bad but
that's one thing Trump is as we know not
a lawyer but here we have the most
senior lawyer in the government of the
United States showing open and unabashed
disdain either for the federal court
system or for Hawaii where he says how
maybe what he means is Hawaii is just
not really a state because they're out
there in the Pacific Ocean I don't know
whether it's disdain for the court
system or for Hawaii but the Attorney
General is supposed to be reverent
toward and fastened to the judicial
branch of government what he's saying is
disturbing and I'm afraid to say that
not only does Jeff sessions have a long
history of this sort of disrespect of
the law but he also has a history of
making racist remarks so it's not
entirely surprising that this is coming
from Jeff sessions maybe it's something
about Native Hawaiians that he has a
problem with I don't know but none of it
is making sense if this ruling had come
from a u.s. district court from Southern
Florida for example would Jeff sessions
have said oh I'm amazed that a judge
from a peninsula between the Gulf of
Mexico and the Atlantic Ocean is able to
make this decision I don't know but this
is very scary stuff great again is
America almost ready to be great again
when you hear the Attorney General
saying embarrassing stuff like this it's
hard to believe that we're any closer to
it
this is being discussed along with many
other stories on our reddit discussion
forum you can subscribe free and
participate at david pakman.com slash
our IDI di t today's program is made
possible in part by Gamefly which is
sort of like netflix for video games
they've got over 8,000 new and classic
games for xbox one Xbox 360 ps4 ps3 Wii
and a bunch of other platforms and you
can also stream games you don't even
need a gaming console or a computer
because you can stream games through
your Amazon fire stick or roku box and
then use your mobile phone
is the controller you can play as many
games as you want for one monthly fee
and if you find some games you want to
keep you can buy them for a low used
price never with due dates or late fees
and our audience can get a 30-day free
trial at Gamefly offer.com slash TDP s
the games are shipped directly to you
with return envelopes included no
contracts and you can also stream the
games I think I mentioned that you can
also rent games through the mobile app
get a free 30 day trial for david pakman
show viewers and listeners and support
our show at Gamefly offer.com forward
slash TDP s